bless up gq this is dj kavan and i'm
going undercover on the internet
this is actually me
seriously it's actually me carrot carrot
carrot dj khaled it's me
okay let's check twitter are you going
back for a rematch on the hot ones
on youtube absolutely not i don't
recommend
nobody doing that to themselves i never
understood
why would you want to put something so
high to try to finish yourself
i'm not here to hurt myself if you want
my advice
don't do that to yourself don't play
yourself
i'm out here promoting my album and my
people's like yo
come just gonna be a fun interview and
we eating chicken wings i'm like
that's great i love chicken wings but
the man start putting all type of sauce
and hot sauce and dip
i'm not into all that i can't i can't
that's not my thing
replied y'all remember when dj khaled
got lost in a jet ski
i remember like it was yesterday i
actually told tom brady the other day
when he
signed with a champ of buccaneers i just
gave him some advice man don't jet ski
at night
because now he live in florida you know
god is great god is the greatest i made
it home
i kept made it home safe and blessed
once you know
no one is better so you know i know not
to jet ski
at night time it's just i'm not doing
that
you're telling me drake nav french
montana and dj
khaled aren't related come on well you
should have put my name first
you should have said you're telling me
dj khaled drake
nav french montana the reason why i say
because if if we do look like each other
they look like me
and those are all my brothers that's
family but you know
ladies i'm taking y'all remember that
video where kanye and dj khaled met on
the runway
and gives him some yeezys and they talk
and then they both just dip off and
to their private jets yeah i'm trying to
be that rich
yeah i remember that i forgot what city
i was in and
i was on my way to my jet and then kanye
was on his way to his jet so we ended up
just
you know bumping into each other on the
runway and after we got done talking
you're saying he gave me his you know
his sneakers because he know i'm a
sneaker head
and i appreciate that and that was love
it was
super historic if you think about it i'm
not expecting to see kanye i'm going i'm
going in my jet
he going his jet and we're bumping each
other in the runway
it's super dope that's a dope picture
that's out there too
yeah it's iconic submit
just found out that dj khaled and his
wife converted their guest house into a
school
so the kids in the community will feel
more normal during the quarantine
super nice of them to take on oh yeah
you know
we have to make sure that our babies and
our kids and and our families are safe
so me and my wife
took the guest house and we made it to a
real school
you know saying like i think we got like
seven students and
everybody's parents and family to this
day is quarantined
um and we follow all the rules and
regulations because we want to be safe
and protect our kids but we also want
our kids
to feel like they still in school
amongst each other instead of like just
a zoom
i don't feel like no kid should go
through you know what we're going
through mentally
you know with this pandemic we want our
kids to stay focused and
have happiness and joy and safety
you know so blessing help other families
and other kids
and that's what we're about at the carol
family and i'm happy that the kids are
still having fun
another one biggest lesson i learned
from dj khaled even if working out
doesn't work out
you keep working out absolutely just
different type of workouts uh first of
all let's talk about
health working out me i like to do
cardio workouts once in a while
as much as possible because i want to
stay healthy i want to make sure that
i do right for my body to give me some
type of movement some people like yo
calorie i don't see you don't lose
weight
cause i don't lose you i'm saying all i
do is win maybe you might not see me get
right away
it comes back it goes it comes back it
goes it comes back it goes
and what i love about that is that i
don't stop and i keep going
and i have a certain number in a weight
that i refuse to go over
so you got to see the keys i'm giving
you because each key leaves the next key
i'm not stopping i'm going to keep going
and i'm gonna keep winning look at me
i'm beautiful like i look sexy i feel
like everything
you know what i'm saying but at the same
time is you gotta be healthy
and that's the key so don't stop
never stop working out cause i'm not
reply people be laughing at dj khaled
with how he talks to his sons and
actually love it
just because they're boys they shouldn't
feel love
from their dad and always show love to
your boys your girls
um to the kids that's what i do first of
all my two boys my two biggest blessings
so when you hear me talking to my kids
and it's the purest form of love it's
the best thing in the world
i thank my wife and god every day for my
kids and they're so beautiful and
they made me greater and they taught me
so much they taught me patience they
taught me
more love and you know when you see that
pure in them and that pure love
it's unbelievable and you want that
feeling
forever you know what i'm saying so yeah
man i talk to my kids and have fun with
my kids and i make sure they smile and
and have a good time every day that's my
job and
those are my boys and i love them posted
how many pairs of sneakers does dj
khaled have
i got three houses with
full sneaker from top to bottom on the
floor
rooms around wrap with sneakers and a
warehouse
filled with sneakers that's too many i
really been
collecting sneakers for a long time but
also love to wear my sneakers
and i love to keep my sneakers all my
properties
and my storages and my warehouses all
sneakers all sneakers all sneakers
jordan baby team jordan another one
all right let me see some youtube
comments putting his son
as an executive producer actually
financially secures his future
is actually real smart um for sure
it's important that we you know make
sure our kids are good forever
with happiness show them what hard work
is and at the same time
secure the future where they wouldn't
have to go through things maybe you had
to go through
you know for me i'm gonna make sure my
voice is good forever
so whatever's mine is theirs obviously
it's my kids
and but at the same time it's by putting
them as executive producers on the album
you know they're already starting a
young age as a mogul
you pray they inspire to take it to the
next level
but it's my job to make sure my kids is
good
and my kids will be good forever because
i'm gonna work hard
and i'm gonna love them so much and i'm
not gonna
stop replied
let's see what's on wikipedia his
musician parents played arabic music i
think on that part
they meant that my family plays arabic
music i grew up
around arabic music of course hip-hop
and soul and jazz and reggae but also
arabic music
and khaled started developing an
interest
into rap and soul music at a young age
and his parents supported his interests
absolutely they supported me 100 they
let me turn my bedroom into a studio
and my garage into a studio he worked at
a local
merry-go-round record store which helped
lay foundation for his music career
the record store was called odyssey
records that's where i met little wayne
on birdman and slim in the beginning of
their career
so that was a great experience um i love
music
you know what i'm saying i started as a
dj still dj i produced
music when i started dj i was a beat
maker at the same
time and then i grew into more of like
it's a producer
next the amount of love dj khaled shows
his wife and his kids
is just unmatched i love it so much i
can't wait to
be loved on every single day oh man i
appreciate that
i love my queen i love my kids i love my
family
my queen she just she a real one she
loved me
she keep me strong you know what i'm
saying and she's so strong
she's so incredible you know i'm saying
and i forever
let her know how much i love her so
beautiful man like
thank you god moving on
let's check out reddit like they're
going to be taking pics together
y'all talking about the dj khaled fat
joe joining only
fans let's be super clear uh joe cracks
my brother and
on the only fans thing you know we want
to inspire
and motivate people you know that's
another platform where you can put
content
and talk to your fans me as a hustler
and a mogul
it's always been somewhere you want to
be ahead of time
and i remember first getting on twitter
i remember first getting on instagram i
remember first getting on snapchat you
know when all these
new platforms come out you know i mean
as long as you put positivity
and love and motivation and inspiration
and that's what we're doing on that
account
we just giving you that claw cloth
talking and spreading that light and
love
replied okay imdb
bless up absolutely that's something i
say every day
all the time that's how i greet people
you know bless up
him saying i'm i'm coming straight out
the gate with love
sending you more love and more blessings
so bless up
they don't want you to yeah i use that
every day that's something i say every
day they don't want you to win
so i'm on gq talking to you winning
that's something i keep in my mind
and i always say callus stay away from
day and stay focused and stay positive
and be in that light and live in that
light and spread that love
and keep winning don't stop another one
absolutely come on you already know what
it is it is another one you know i'm
saying i say that all the time
cause i keep making these hits and i'm
gonna keep doing that because my fans
inspire me
so every time i go in the studio it's
going to be
another one and speaking of another one
the new album coming it's called cat
mccallitt
it's in the works and it's another one
you smart you loyal 100 percent
when you tell somebody you smart and
you're loyal that's the biggest
compromise one of the biggest compliment
i look in the mirror every day say i'm
small and loyal and i even
you know i i'm a genius what's wrong
with telling somebody that
when they moving smart and they loyal
and they ingenious
let them know let them know
major key yeah you know i always i said
i say that every day too because it's
important that people know what major
keys is
you know i mean god is the master key
what's so beautiful about the keys they
never run out and each key leads to the
next key
and when each key leads to the next key
you're gonna get a major key
you know going through the keys because
there's
keys and then there's major key and then
there's
major key alert that's when it's like oh
you know what i mean like doing gq
that's the major key
you know what i'm saying man that was a
good list no strong no strong
okay that's it i'm signing off on the
internet remember
when you're on the internet show love
spread love make somebody smile
motivate inspire the light is love
god is love god is the greatest
coward cowan bless up